foreign
[Music]
skateboarder sipping on some cranberry
yeah
Tick Tock star Nathan Apodaca has used
his 15 minutes of fame to launch himself
into an acting gig hey cool let's go
dude dude who attracted headlines around
the world for skateboarding down the
road drinking cranberry juice and
listening to Fleetwood Mac CEO of Good
Vibes whole vibe yeah that's the best
the best [ __ ] Vibes is hit the big
time he earned himself a guest spot on
Hulu's reservation dog oh cool the show
created by New Zealand cinematic genius
taika white
is an indigenous American Comedy drama
series set in Oklahoma that follows the
ups and downs of Teenage life
show has an All-American indigenous cast
and also boasts an almost entirely
indigenous North American cast and
production team that's dope even the
production that's sick that is really
sick Apple daca's Tick Tock garnered
more than 13.4 million likes after it
was posted and it spawned copycat videos
from the ogs themselves Mick Fleetwood
and Stevie Nicks of Fleetwood Mac Wow as
well as other celebrities including
Shakira and Gordon Ramsay Shakira Gordon
wrap that's so odd but remember the
reason behind is mode of Transport
actually came from hardship 37 year old
began skateboarding and work when his
car wouldn't start oh yeah so it's just
a video on Tic Tac that everybody felt
to Vibe with he said back in 2020 I'm
happy I could chill the world out for a
minute yeah I guess we should say it in
his wife's glad Bart I don't even know
what his voice sounds like what does it
look like
I just want to chill the the world out
very good exactly I just want to chill
so he's Native American he's not Mexican
I think he's happy
oh heifer that's why he has the feather
tattoos oh that's what it sounds like
maybe now he talks like that he shot the
viral video man
Chino over there he shot that viral
video uh when he was on his way to work
at a potato farm after his video went
viral an Ocean Spray representative
showed up at his home in Idaho Falls
Idaho with a gift a cranberry red car
with its uh trunk full of juice the sick
ass [ __ ] truck right here check us
out imagine going [ __ ] viral for your
Tick Tock video and then you get a car
full of Ocean Spray That's So Dope that
was crazy it looked like a Nissan
Frontier the amount of publicity that he
gave Ocean Spray Ocean Spray wouldn't
have been able to buy that I don't know
at all yeah like that's like millions
millions and millions it's a deal for
them to give them this truck that's
nothing and in a Fleetwood Mac too they
got a bump in their purchases and yeah
huge this fool put [ __ ] Fleetwood
like back on the map and Ocean Spray for
a second you wanted to say Fleetwood
back huh I did
is like the best road trip music
it is it's [ __ ] it's a joke man they
are dope man that's the best road trip
like would you just driving for miles
and [ __ ] and you see the sunset just
like oh [ __ ] yeah dude I'm a gypsy crazy
man like they're banned like a bunch of
members like dated each other married
each other dated each flipped just
[ __ ] each other how the [ __ ] is crazy
they're doing these songs that they
wrote for you know for each other but
now they're with someone else in the
band so some songs like they're singing
to this person that's the guitarist and
the other song
just having random connections on stage
flit was on the back of the job like I
[ __ ] all these [ __ ]
I'm happy that I could chill the world
out for a minute I feel like that's like
a Tick-Tock [ __ ] advertisement that's
true because that was a positive thing
that happened during the whole [ __ ]
lockdown yeah dude it was just so much
good [ __ ] happens to good people yeah
every now and then and he was just
chilling and just just cool with it he
just like he's being himself I remember
before he blew up on that he was uh on
the very popular page food's gone wild
that's why I saw him initially but it
was gone wild
oh man dude so this guy was so funny
because he would just put like any
random song and then dance in the
factory yeah and like just do funny ass
videos I was like oh this dude is
[ __ ] hilarious and then when he
posted that one that's when he [ __ ]
popped and he blew up so he was doing
contact before he's already doing
contact yeah is he Fool's gone wild
because they would always if the whole
premise of was gonna wild is like all
the cholos of the world yeah cholo
comedy and their their catchphrase is
the higher the socks the downer the food
it's so funny we know because we grew up
our lives like that new show kind of not
called this fool and I'm like oh yeah
it's like 100 get the show yeah and and
he was like one of the main guys they
would always share on Foods in the wild
and that's how I was like he was always
just dancing and having a good time yeah
just the funniest dances and then he
post that video and it blew up yeah
shout out to dog face yeah let's watch
this video One More Time Feel Good Vibes
The Good Vibes just the Good Vibes you
gotta talk over the the song though so
we won't get [ __ ] algorithm
[Music]
cool it was it was repeating it felt
good where's he at now I was trying 13.4
million likes you still get a strike for
singing along though that's why I wasn't
saying the words
yeah but we were doing it bad you get
stretched how many how many is it views
13 well I don't know if you use the 13.4
million likes so it's way more views so
I said 10 should I say likes is probably
10 so like 130 million and that's not
even counting the poached reposts just
from skating and vibing out see because
it's so relatable people know what that
feels like yeah with the [ __ ] just
riding us the message dude especially
during covet we were just all at home
or especially if it's like oh yeah dude
like my car broke down and I needed to
get to work on the potato farm in Idaho
yeah yeah
the backstory really did it for me
because I didn't know all I thought was
oh that shit's [ __ ] dope and then
like you thought this was in L.A yeah I
did too yeah I thought so for a second
yeah it's like Fourth Street or
something I thought it was I thought it
was one of those New Mexico Arizona
Pomona some [ __ ] yeah that's what makes
Inland Empire cholo you know because he
looks like an OG so it looks cool yeah
and then when other people try to
recreate it you realize like man he's
the only one that could do it dude he's
the only one yeah because it's pure it's
pure so he's going like this and he's
holding Ocean Spray cranberry juice I'm
down for one lucky break where I'm just
like I don't know doing nothing but
drinking juice or some [ __ ] and then
suddenly I get to be like in mood do you
even record yourself drinking juice
though see that's where you [ __ ] up
Anthony Lee you don't even do the work
to start yeah you don't even I've never
seen you drink juice you think off this
one little thing he did he got obviously
got a car game Ocean Spray
I think I saw a video of him uh because
he he used to live in a trailer and I
think he bought a house and there's this
one video of like him and I think his
daughter like crying because they're
finally gonna have a home wow sick he
got a house off there okay this
[ __ ] deserves it God damn it dog
face man he's the man bro he's the man
so um
pick up pick up
quick mess when I saw this though it
actually got me back into skating like
yeah me too yeah when I saw this I was
like I remember he kind of took me back
into being 14 with me and my friends
just like riding all [ __ ] day and so
me and my friends started just going to
the boardwalk at uh Venice and we would
just ride on your longboards yeah on our
longboards one just came back to us
today let's go one just came back from
our local dog face local dog face and
Adobe always like someone on a bike so
he could hold on to the bike if we get
tired you guys want to know how I'll
hang out with you guys at JK go skating
if we all get long boards and we all
just cruised the boardwalk dude yeah
cool you ever seals like Asian girls on
the killing on the longboard dude when
they walk up and down
do that [ __ ] it's so sexy running like
this skinny little Asian girls look like
an anime [ __ ] and I'm like what the [ __ ]
pop on the front two wheels and spin the
board around that's crazy looking all
cute I'm like how the [ __ ] while filming
themselves just going forward the whole
time just like walking dancing up and
down and flip it up so I can come back
down
how to do that [ __ ] I feel like so many
scales and talents came out out of
lockdown like roller skating [ __ ] it
long boarding and then the [ __ ] that
they're doing it's like damn it's so
tight hacking
crypto scams get the [ __ ] out of people
crypto scams yeah cryptos camps I lost
some crypto money scams and [ __ ]
dieting I got into mountain biking that
[ __ ] was fun dude got into and got out
of it your Mountain bike's been over
there collecting dust for a minute I
don't have a place to go anymore I got a
mountain on a mountain bike is scary
well for me Summer was mountain biking
and then winter was snowboarding that
[ __ ] was time
let's bring that mountain bike to
friggin Hawaii
oh that's Diamond Head all that [ __ ]
okay
yes but I missed Santa's Village man
they got raps and jumps and [ __ ] Santa's
a village dude I know it's crazy when
you drive these by these skate parks now
these kids got skate parks in the middle
of town yeah I know who the [ __ ] was
this when I was like I know it's pretty
cool
there was like two when we were kids now
it's everywhere everywhere but that was
like also kind of like the thing right
there was like almost just like uh every
Community had like that little mini
leader of the community like you know
I'm gonna open up a skate park from my
town and then it just happened like
eight times after Tony I did it now it's
happening yeah now it's cool but like
I'm not a good skater so I also think
like if I'm just there with a skateboard
I can't do [ __ ] I can't do [ __ ] I look
like and now it's a great place I can do
[ __ ] work everybody's gonna yell you
for being the way you're like what are
you doing here I was like I don't know
it's a playground I can't play in it's
just grounding me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]